is out of there with it
ant off the feed and anthony edwards
showing that ants can kill
wow nobody in this building can believe
it's ridiculous
anthony's just
absolutely destroyed gabe vincent on
that play
oh my goodness
that was nasty
this crowd is energized
and bam never left the lane i mean i
don't i don't know how you don't call
that three seconds i need to see that
dunk again i need to see how long bam
adebayo was in the paint
there's a lot of things we need to see
i still don't know how that
got called against edwards towns gets
stripped that time
vincent dumps it off for adebayo and
they're going to call the offensive foul
as tori and prince gave up the body
[Music]
[Applause]
here's the here's the offensive file
that just happened yeah i don't know
what gabe vincent is saying he's saying
it's bad i mean it's it was a great play
by turian prince here's the dunk door
cut
he got outside the restricted area
wow but i'm not sure he got there before
ant elevated though i don't know i think
i think he's ants up in the air
elevating and he's just getting his feet
set
it's just bang bang this game is